what do you what do you have in your
sub-conscience
a subconscious about mary poppins the
the original that made you want to see
more and want to be a part of this what
was the thing from your first memory
well for me it was I think in my blood
because and I think a lot of people feel
that way it's my first film I saw I was
four years old
1964 so that dates me right there and
but I remember it I remember the feeling
of it I remember that more than anything
the feeling of joy the feeling of magic
the feeling of wonder and music and
dance and all of that which informed me
for the rest of my life and I really
feel like in a way when this came to us
and came to me of course we were I was
nervous and trepidatious and and daunted
by all of it but then I thought to
myself well wait a minute if someone's
gonna do it I want to do it because I
want to pay homage to that brilliant
film with great care and thoughtfulness
and passion and love and I and I hope
you feel that in every frame in terms of
the homage to the original film because
that's really what I felt and I but at
the same time we wanted to do you know I
wanted to create an original musical
which I'd never done before and that was
a dream of mine because I've always
wanted to do that and and so it just
felt like this was the way to do that
and we wanted to find our own path to
create an original story from the very
beginning with this amazing team Emily
Lin do you have memories of when you saw
the film first sure I mean I I think I
was about it was the first movie I ever
saw no I'm just trying to make you feel
less old no I think I saw it around six
or seven and the lasting memory that I
have of it was yes the magic and yes the
Wonder but the safety I felt in her
hands you know this magical and yet
sensible
person who came into these people's
lives and she swept everything up and
she made it right again and the idea of
bringing order to chaos and that you're
in good hands and that she will work it
out and you'll discover so much about
yourself in the process I think that
idea of she is a sort of savior she's
like this sort of angel who is really
batty and eccentric at the same time and
I just remember her really and then when
I took on the project when Rob called me
about it
I was filled with you know simultaneous
thrill and fear you know because I knew
I had my work cut out for me very much
so with this character that has
imprinted in such a profound way on some
the world universally you know so it was
that idea well how do I create my
version of her what is my version of her
and and that seemed like a very exciting
prospect that this is the next chapter
and there's more magic to tell there are
more stories to tell and the whole
experience was completely life-affirming
for me it was just a delight she is such
a delight to play just delicious so then
when did you first see it I think I had
a fluffy white VHS cassette I don't know
if you kids you won't remember this but
we always had the Disney VHS cassettes
were just a little bigger than the other
cassettes they were like fluffy and
puffy and white and they didn't fit in
the rack with everyone else yeah very
satisfying - they were huggable VHS
cassettes and so I had that cassette and
I saw the first two-thirds of the movie
hundreds of times but I could never get
through feed the birds because that
melody was so sad
that I would burst into tears and turn
off the movie I didn't see the I didn't
see step in time in the end of the movie
till I was like in high school
I was I was I'm very melody sensitive
and so but
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious for a
word lover like me was the greatest song
ever written and the fact that this word
was invented for this song and I have a
I have a best friend Arthur Lewis who we
became best friends cuz he was the only
kid I knew who could spell it backwards
and forwards it was like an intelligence
test when you're a nerd like me so it's
it's when we started taking on this
project again you remember how much of
the movie every bit of it is in your DNA
I burst into tears when I saw the votes
for women sash on the kite you know it's
there's just so much that we don't even
realize is baked into our collective
unconscious mark do you have people who
are going to be expecting it to look a
certain way to sound a certain way and
how were you working with ROM to make
sure that you were able to create this
world what were some of the challenges
of you well there's no greater joy for a
producer in the world particularly
producer who loves musicals as I do to
have the opportunity to work with Rob
Marshall as your producer and director
so it begins with that and and and and
my partner John DeLuca and Rob's partner
and it began with of course the love of
the original film I was seven when I saw
it a little older than Rob and I
remember those were the days you got
dressed up and my parents took me
downtown I lived in the suburbs of
Baltimore and it was like a big deal and
I thought I I remember thinking as I
grew up would I ever be able to be a
participant in a film like that and as I
had a career in Hollywood I wondered
what Hollywood ever make movies like
that again and thank goodness we had the
opportunity to make a film like this in
this particular moment in time and what
gave me of course the confidence is the
love that everybody here hasn't
everybody making the film had for that
film the original film starting with Rob
so Rob and John came up and David McGee
are wonderful screenwriter for kate
looked into the P L Travers books
there's seven books there's Ned they're
only episodes but they're they're
delightful episodes and then they came
up on the room with this incredible
story that is really really magical and
a read
know that sets it in the depression so
there's a relevancy to today terms of
the challenges the families facing and
then David went off and wrote this
fantastic screenplay at the same time
I've got Marc Shaiman and Scott Whitman
at the table with Rob writing these
credible songs these marvelous lyrics
again with such a love and passion for
the original but making it their own and
then mark scoring the film beyond the
song so brilliantly and so it for as a
Purdue to and then a magnificent team of
designers like John and and Sandeep alva
costumes and Dionne bee-bees marvelous
photography so there's a producer I know
that was very long-winded answer but
this is the joy this has been the joy of
my life it starts with this man these
glorious actors and all those actors you
saw and it comes at a time where we all
need it so badly to remember possibility
and and the fact that not only do we
want to remember our childhood we
actually need to now so that's my
experience on Mary Bob what was the
hardest task of having the return in
this news story and at the same time
pain it's creating the world that felt
like it belonged to what have been
created by the Sherman Brothers asking
what was the hardest part of it yeah
well what was the easiest part the
Sherman Brothers are right there and
then
oh we're gonna also write songs for
lin-manuel Miranda so I got to the piano
[Laughter]
that would be the hardest part
everything else and so Meryl Streep and
Angela Lansbury and Emily Blunt no
problem no what was going through your
head as all of this came shooting down
the pike to you to make real
well first off how fun is all that I
just always say I have the best job at
the entire world and I think everyone
here feels they have the best job in the
entire world and this movie was possibly
our best mark and I tease each other
whenever we work together and say this
is our best one yet mark always grumbles
but last night he came to me and he said
you know what John this is the best one
yeah I had a great introduction to this
because and we haven't really talked
about this but maybe 9 10 years ago when
we were doing 9 we started talking about
Mary Poppins and you let me in on this
wonderful story where you knew Julie
Andrews and Tony Walton and they told
you Tony Walton told you where he got
inspiration for some of the sets from
the first movie and so I went on a hunt
I had my little notes from you
and I went to all the parks trying to
find houses that look like boats and and
found the boltons crescents so I had
been waiting for the phone call from you
for 10 years we actually designed the
ride well we were location scouting on a
movie yeah so so it was it was kind of
deep in all of our Bloods yeah so Emily
I want to ask you I from watching the
film I think everybody can actually feel
it when Mary Poppins comes floating down
which must have been a fun shot I don't
know exactly how you did that but not
frightening at all
yeah I had the best seat in the house
for that one I mean not that I could see
Lynn because Lynn was like that big you
know that was a practical shot she's 60
feet up on a line coming down I thought
I was alright with Heights until I was
up there and then I realized I wasn't
you know it's just and I just remember
being up there and thinking and that
really was the moment that entrance
where Rob very helpfully and in a very
emboldened
lead the incredible score blaring from
the speakers and so it did help me sort
of get over my yeah we probably messed
up the shot over at solo which was
shooting on the same but it was that
moment of come and it was all in one
shot so I start this big in the air and
I come down and I have to walk into the
shot and start speaking and so but there
was that moment up there where I was
like oh my god I'm Mary Poppins and
Meryl Streep when she saw that maybe she
goes how much you pay Rob Marshall for
that entrance response talk about
producing the music for this and making
this very lush I think soundtrack and
and making this whole thing seamless
well something Emily said reminding me
now this is where Rob Marshall is some
kind of mad genius because before we
filmed he asked me to write a whole
bunch of score and I was like you're
crazy how can I score nothing he said
well this has got to be this and it's
the sequence in this and I want to have
this music on the set so I went back to
New York and in our hiatus or Christmas
hiatus and I read the script and then I
actually read the script like a radio
play including all the stage directions
and I I tried to read it in the pace so
I imagined it might be in the movie but
you know things change when you film a
movie so I was like you know scoring is
so specific how can I do this but I just
finally just trusted he he had he had
trust and we recorded all this score
before they filmed so that they did have
music when they were filming and I'll be
damned if every single piece of music
that we filmed recorded before they
filmed is all still in the movie like
like bespoke I mean we we barely made
any adjustments on those specific cues
because he just he has it in his head
and and then he puts it up there and I'd
never experienced anything like that
yeah like when we're riding to Topsy's
house and it's like done and sort of
like the pre reprise of Topsy song and
serve this jazzy score we were blasting
that on the streets of London and the
whole tempo every every actor who's
walking by as we're going is is going to
that tempo it really does set the mood
for for everybody and it's it's like
what what better way to sort of put us
all in a pop in space especially if
we're in a practical location to pick up
on that because mark makes it sound so
easy but I have to go back just again to
Rob because the his movies seemed so
seamless and so effortless directing an
original musical and one this
complicated for reasons you're now
getting a glimpse of starting with the
amount of artists the amount of crafts
women and craftsmen who flocked to work
with Rob directing an original musical
is really really challenging and
sophisticated not just the songs and the
score the things that are obvious
there's a musicality that's built into
the way the camera moves the way the
lighting is the way transitions from
scene to scene if you look at that
animated sequence alone think about it
start it with an idea in Rob's head it
becomes a song and lyric it gets
arranged it gets orchestrated it is lit
it has an whole animation team under
Rob's Direction inventing the story
inventing this world if you will he's
got the best actors in the world doing
their best work and then it's all
choreographed there are penguins and
life people doing he does the
choreography with his partner John it
notes like the Penguins a little heavier
on the cane when you pull him it's
really and I say that just because I
because it's all true and as I said in
the beginning you're so lucky to get to
work with Rob I've sat on the stage
before with some marvelous directors and
in musicals as well and this this man is
really something special and you're
getting a glimpse in these little
details as to why but you make it look
so easy and the other thing I want to
say is the easiest job for a producer is
casting a Rob Marshall movie because if
reactor in this town wants to come work
with Rob and you see why it's just
beautiful so Rob thank you for all from
all of us really thank you very much
thanks everybody